hi tech editor Jimmy here I'm with
Michael the associate tech editor here
at gamespot and we're here to talk about
Microsoft's project Scorpios new
revealed specs the company recently
spoke with a digital foundry and we're
going to walk you through some of those
new tech specs so we already knew that
the project Scorpio was going to use a
soc or system-on-a-chip that integrates
the cpu and GPU on a single die which is
pretty common for consoles but we
learned a couple things it still has
eight CPU Jaguar CPU cores but they've
actually been overclocked original xbox
one had a 1.75 gigahertz frequency CPU
that's been updated to 2.3 Microsoft has
also made some hardware implementations
for DirectX 12 directly on to the GPU
they say significantly reduces draw
calls and also yes this is a six
teraflop solution which microsoft sort
of hinted at e3 last year to put that
into perspective this is most similar to
perhaps the Radeon our X 480 GPU which
has 5.8 teraflops this is up from 1.3
one of the original xbox one moving on
to the the ram the system actually has
12 gigabytes of gddr5 memory this is up
four gigabytes from the xbox one
solution but it uses a faster gddr5
memory which is what actually the ps4
probably uses this is faster than the
xbox one slower ddr3 solution from what
they're saying eight gigabytes of it is
going to be used for games the rest of
the four gigabytes is going to be used
for overhead for like the CPU the OS and
things like that so the one game that
Microsoft showed off project Scorpio
running was Forza and we both had a
chance to take a look at that Michael
what were your impressions on that so
they were running the Forza tech engine
in 4k and they were hitting 60 FPS with
a significant room for like the GPU
percentage was around 60 I'll 7 up to 7
yeah of you send which is impressive
which means there's more room for
there's more horsepower under the hood
yeah so the Forza tech demo was using
the settings that would be on an xbox
one and just porting that over to the
Scorpio hardware
so it was we made up the res to native
4k which is impressive but essentially
use the same graphic settings for that
so in terms of extra fidelity that we
saw it was a simply resolution so I and
we have now we have questions about like
well is it just going to be a 4k
resolution are we go is also going to
have extra texture filtering better
lighting higher res textures within the
game those are all questions that i
think are still on the table but being
able to run 4k 60fps on a console is
impressive within itself it's just that
we want yeah we just want to see it in
more examples in the future which we
will get obviously it doesn't work with
games right out of the box per se you
know Microsoft and its developers its
partners have to go back and retweet the
games in order for you to get these
performance editions yeah and that's
expected just because it's on the pc
that is in the case though i didn t see
this kind of scale though yeah i mean i
don't want to get into game dev but like
before a pc game comes out that stuff is
already implemented in terms of like
graphic settings what those are scaling
yeah before it's released right so if
you're going to go back into the entire
library of xbox games is of course it's
going to take time to like rethink that
and make the games run in sync with the
new hardware what do you think this
means for existing games i think
microsoft said that they were kind of
hoping that games that are running at
900p right now to not only you know run
it like 1080p but 4k you're gonna have
to make compromises with other like
graphic settings and frame rate marks
that you want to hit being able to have
native 4k i think is like within a
console it's like it's unprecedented and
it's this is the most powerful console
that we've seen so far it had to be the
graphics card is Elvis and an equivalent
to the Radeon r x 480 which i have
actually used them a lot of benchmarks
and the arcs variety is an impressive
card for where it is in terms of pricing
it's not the best but it is still a very
good card but i'm having trouble hitting
4k 60fps on that graphics card
so I'm wondering if you know if we're
going to hit that resolution what else
are we bringing down to hit the FPS mark
that they want do you think this is more
powerful than the ps4 problem the answer
is yes just from a tech perspective yes
this is more powerful than the ps4 pro
it had to be and it was expected to be
and it is in terms of how it's going to
be how games are gonna work with it and
how developers are going to interact
with new hardware is the question that
can only be answered once it's out and
once we see games running on it but yes
it is more powerful and just because it
the tear the tech specs teraflops
running something in native 4k 60fps we
seen it so the potential is there with
the ps4 pro you every game has some sort
of ps4 pro patch I don't know if Xbox
games are going to have that or if it's
just going to recognize this game okay
let's run it in 4k and like blast it out
to whatever display you're using so they
mentioned that everything is going to be
rendered in 4k and then if you're on a
1080p display it's going to do 1080p and
super sample it to 4k which is I think
that's super impressive I'm a big fan of
super sampling but it's in very
demanding especially on PC hardware yeah
but like if you're if that's the case
with running on a 1080p display games
are going to look very clean right so
super sampling is basically you're
running the game at 4k and then 4k is
you know four times pixel density has
1080p and you're shrinking that down to
a 1080p display and that actually makes
a 1080p display look actually sharper
than it is word on the street is that
this is the scorpios going to be 499 I
don't think it can be any higher than
that if it's lower than that that's
really cool but considering how how
powerful this is I think that 499 would
be reasonable anything other than that
it might get a little bit dicey so that
was our analysis of Microsoft's projects
Scorpio if you liked this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to us on
YouTube thanks for watching
you
[Music]